bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour ce 78 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre émission rugby Chevreuse et
Versailles sont relégués en Division
Honneur la saison prochaine les
chevretins se sont inclinés contre
châteurou et Versailles a perdu sur le
terrain d'ser les détails dans ce
magazine
football la morpa s'est imposé au tir au
but contre guancour en demi-finale de
Coupe des ivines l'équipe des firalimé à
plaisir le 5 juin prochain plus
d'informations à suivre basket féminin
l'entente le chaîn Versailles s'est
incliné sur le terrain des codin lors
des barrages le score est lourd 85 à 59
nous recevons dans quelques instants les
joueus Julie FAM et perine chanlon et
puis nous parlerons également de golf le
numéro 3 mondiale l'Irlandais Rory
mckilroy participera à l'Open de France
de golf en juin prochain au golf
national de cqutin
d'iveline on commence ce magazine par du
rugby en fédéral 3 Chevreuse termine le
championnat à la dernière place du
classement après sa défaite contre
châurou sur le score de 20 à 13 les
chevretins évolueront donc dans le
championnat Honneur la saison prochaine
Camille amambert pour les images c'était
un match à kit tout double les chevretin
dernier du classement de fédéral 3 avant
la rencontre devait battre le 2e châurou
pour se maintenir dans la division après
un combat de 80 minutes les rouges et
bleus yvelinois n'ont pas réussi à créer
d'exploit sur leur pelouse score final
20 13 manque de discipline beaucoup de
pénalités contre nous et puis un peu un
manque de créativité on a mal exploité
nos ballons c'est une accumulation pas
mal de choses on narrive pas à mettre de
la vitesse comme on devrait la mettre je
sais pas c'est compliqué on est
aujourd'hui on était dernier ils sont
deuxè donc forcément il y a un écart de
niveau on n pas réussi à palier cet
écart et on échou pas grand chose
finalement avec cette défaite Chevreuse
termine dernier du classement de la
pooule 3 avec un bilan de 5 victoires et
13 défaites cette saison l'équipe
évoluera en honneur lors de l'exercice
2016-27 je pense pas que c'était trop
dur je pense qu'on était au niveau il
nous a manqué peut-être un peu
d'effectif pour faire tourner les
joueurs fatigués et cetera et puis une
gestion dans les fins de match ça aurait
pu être différent ça aurait pu être
différent après voilà avec desess saison
difficile on en sous effectif toute la
saison c'est très compliqué de de
réussir à se maintenir à ce niveau-là
donc donc une grande déception sur la
saison complète et mais après ça bah va
falloir reconstruire quelque chose
l'année prochaine le club a déjà annoncé
les objectifs pour la saison prochaine
Chevreuse visera dans un premier temps
le maintien en honneur avant de penser à
la
montée après Chevreuse on continue notre
tour d'horizon sur cette fin de saison
de fédéral 3 dans la poule 2 Versailles
n'a pas réussi l'exploit de battre
auosser à l'extérieur les Versailles se
sont inclinés 46 à 22 cette défaite
condamne les joueurs de la cité royale à
la division honur l'année prochaine pour
nous parler de la saison du club nous
recevons sur ce plateau le président
Olivier nerenf et également le directeur
technique du RCV Nicolas Nicolas loubar
alors président est-ce que c'était une
descente inéluctable finalement sur
quand quand on voit les les derniers
résultats alors en fait tout s'est joué
à Pont à Mousson il y a à peu près 3
semaines et si on avait pas perdu d'un
point et avec une pénalité manquée face
au poteau à 35 m à la dernière action le
l'histoire été aurait été peut-être
différente mais hier allit jouer à auxer
une semaine des play-off auxer termine
premier des 16 pou de la Fédérale 3 avec
16 victoires sur 18 matchs et un goal à
varage pratiquement de 500 points
positifs c'était très compliqué donc en
fait on a tenu une mi-temps 12-3 à la
mi-temps c'était déjà un expoir
malheureusement on a eu en 5 minutes ne
la 3ème ligne blessé et on a fini le
match avec difficulté mais on a eu un
Barou d'onur formidable dans les 10
dernières minutes on a marqué trois ESS
ils avaient pas l'habitude de prendre
des essai comme ça donc finalement on
savait que ça serait compliqué on y
allait en disant qu'on pouvait le faire
mais bon l'histoire c'est faite avant
Nicolas loubar cette équipe d'osser
n'était pas prenable du tout euh non non
non réellement parce qu'en fait c'était
une équipe très puissante ils ont des
joueurs étrangers qui viennent qui ont
qui ont joué à des niveaux beaucoup plus
élevés que la fédéral 3 euh donc ils ont
cette puissance en fait et d'ailleurs
c'est leur façon de jouer c'est leur
leur marque de jeu de de jouer
principalement chez les avants avec des
touches et des molles donc c'est un jeu
stéréotypé qui leur convient qui met en
avant leur puissance et pour nous qui
avons des gabarit des joueurs issus du
club qui sont beaucoup plus flués bon
c'est c'est plus difficile leur a fallu
avoir être encore plus agressif parce
qu'on a bien tenu en défense la première
mi-temps de continuer à l'être en
deuxième mi-temps là où nous avons lâché
justement et et justement et aussi de
mettre beaucoup plus de vitesse chose
qu'on n' pas réussi à trouver Olivier le
disait à l'instant cette équipe
finalement d'ser c'est c'est quasiment
une équipe de fédéral 2 au final euh oui
pour moi c'est une équipe quasiment de
fédéral 2 parce que en fait il ils sont
déjà constitués ils se préparent déjà
c'est aussi dans les objectifs du club
faut savoir la politique du club
laquelle all est pour pour celui-ci euh
donc il mettent les moyens financiers en
terme de joueurs et cetera euh bon c'est
une valeur que dans lequel nous nous ne
nous reconnaissons pas
voilà
nous tout à fait ils ont un budget
beaucoup plus conséquent nous on aime le
jeu le Ruby de base et on aime former
les joueurs vous avez quand même réussi
marquer président trois essais TR ESS
match des meilleures équipes finalement
de de fédéral 3 donc c'est c'est un
Barou d'onneur voilà on a marqué 6 essis
mais dans tous les cas vous avez quand
même réussi à marquer TR essais voilà
donc finalement c'est vraiment un Barou
d'onneur et en fait on l'a fait à
l'opposé du stéréotype des groupés
pénétrants d'xer par du contourement de
l'explosivité et des longues courses et
avec des essai de 80 80 m 100 m on
appelle ça du French et au final vous le
disiez peut-être que voilà la saison ne
se joue pas finalement sur ce dernier
match elle se joue bien avant président
alors tout le monde est responsable
làdedans les joueurs l'encadrement même
la direction du club et puis aussi alors
dans ces cas-là quand les choses vont
pas bien il y a toujours la M chance qui
vient aussi s'ajouter au problème avec
des avec des pénalités qui sont sur les
bar avec au moin nombre de choses mais
la réussite ça c'est vrai qu'il faut
aller la chercher mais la réussite aussi
il faut l'avoir cette équipe elle ne
manquait pas d'expérience il y avait
énormément de de jeunes joueurs de
joueurs âgés de 20 ans le problème ne
vient pas de là justement de de ce
manque d'expérience dans dans les matchs
clés peut-être oui peut-être mais aussi
on avait quand même perdu un certain
nombre de joueurs l'année dernière qui
sont plutôt des trentenaires et c'est
des gens qui sont partis ailleurs pour
d'autres projets donc on a deux joueurs
qui ont entraîné mant liim qui est
devenu champion d'île-de-fance en
promotion d'honneur et qui vont être en
honneur l'année prochaine et qu'on
risque de retrouver en concurrent le
dimanche donc on a perdu un 100 nombre
de joueurs on a compensé par quelques
arrivées mais devant on était pas assez
puissant pas assez puissant il y a eu
des erreurs de casting peut-être sur
cette année euh et bien en fait si vous
voulez le le casting il ne se il ne se
fait pas notre guise c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait euh nous c'est vraiment bah des
joueurs issus du du cru versailla il y a
eu une venue de de joueurs issus de de
Suren que les entraîneurs ont eu la
chance de d'entraîner plus jeune euh
toutefois après si euh je vous comme je
vous l'ai dit c'est question de moyens
donc on peut pas attirer les meilleurs
joueurs les plus grands puissants je
pense que il faut qu'on démontre qu'on a
une identité de jeu à Versailles et je
pense qu'elle n'est pas celle-là donc
peut-être si un jour on a un gros
sponsur on on cherchera des joueurs mais
en tout cas on cherchera pas des joueurs
extrêmement puissants ce n'est pas notre
marque de favorque l'année prochaine
vous allez garder les mêmes joueurs que
cette année ou vous allez changer
l'effectif nous sommes en PH
d'introspection déjà commencé donc
l'analyse de la saison est déjà en cours
est un fait que c'est un moment crucial
du club parce que il faut prendre les
décisions et prendre des décisions ça
peut éventuellement entraîner des
changements et à ce moment-là il y a des
gens qui sont AFF liés à à certains à
certaines personnes donc on sait très
bien qu'une descente avec des groupes
qui constituent même une équipe première
ça peut entraîner des des départs donc
il y a vraiment une mayonnaise à à
construire il a des jeunes peut-être qui
peuvent monter également en équipe en
équipe une et ben notre force c'est
vraiment la formation jeune puisquon a
420 personnes 420 jeunes entre 6 et 20
et 20 ans maintenant on a une période d'
1 an à 2 ans à attendre pour que tout
soit mû et parfaitement en place mais
l'optimisme est là parce que c'est
Nicolas loubar justement directeur
technique a pris ça en main et je vais
dire faire de la formation c'est bien
d'en parler mais si il faut le faire et
actuellement on est en train de le faire
sérieusement et vous allez repartir avec
le même staff ça pour le moment c'est la
phase d'introspection qui est en cours
également il y a besoin peut-être de
stabilité dans ce club également Nicolas
euh de
stabilité je sais pas je sais pas si
c'est une notion de de
stabilité au niveau du staff St je sais
pas pour pour moi il faut il faut on est
en train de se poser les les bonnes
questions justement donc on a un retour
avec les joueurs à savoir comment ils se
sont sentis comment nous on évalue
justement le la qualité de de de
l'entraînement euh et puis aussi euh il
y a aussi une certaine part de notre une
certaine part de responsabilité parce
que il faut savoir comment on confie les
clés du camion aussi au staff donc euh
voilà il faut il faut il faut vraiment
étudier ça on va voir on ira très vite
Olivier neur justement c'est c'est ma
prochaine question vous il faudra
s'habituer à voir Versailles en honneur
ou dès l'année prochaine vous voulez
remonter au niveau fédéral de toute
façon euh vu vu notre ancienneté vu
parce qu'on bon j'ai vraiment vraent une
expérience très lointaine puisque je
viens de l'autre siècle et que j'ai fait
des montées et des descentes en tant que
joueur en tant que dirigeant maintenant
en tant que Président c'est la première
donc de toute façon on est condamné à
revenir le plus vite possible en fédéral
alors après on verra merci à tous les
deux d'être passé sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite bon courage pour la saison
prochaine on vous souhaite évidemment de
remonter au niveau fédéral le plus
rapidement possible merci à vous alors
on passe maintenant au résultats de
plaisir dans cette poule une de fédéral
3 plaisir n'a fait qu'une bouchée de
maison la fite ce weekend les Plaisirois
se sont imposés 33 à0 dans ce derby
yvelinois les hommes coachés par Jean-M
terminent donc les phases de poule à la
2è place du classement derrière
rengistre avec un bilan de 16 victoire
et deux défaites après le rugby on passe
à notre rubrique
football en football la demi-finale de
Coupe des iblin entre morpa et guencour
était programmée jeudi soir au stade du
boutéclos les morpasiens se sont
qualifiés pour la finale au terme d'une
séance de tir au but le résumé du match
un derby sulfureux pour cette
demi-finale de Coupe des Yvelines ce
jeudi Laas morpa recevait au stade du
bout des clos en cour sa-quentin après
30 premières minutes équilibré le Guan
courtois W Dialo fait faute en position
de dernier défenseur l'arbitre Stéphane
Freddy n'hésite pas carton rouge réduit
à 10 les hommes de Jud talmorose vont
subir avant de craquer sur un coup franc
le milieu défensif de morpa Frédéric
ester s'élève plus haut que les
défenseurs à la 43e minute 1-0 première
mi-temp qui était qui était assez engagé
des deux côtés il avait pas beaucoup
d'espace pour jouer les ballons c'était
difficile donc donc du coup c'était
vraiment assez assez arg au milieu
derrière c'était dur donc on on a réussi
à marquer ce petit but juste avant la
mi-temps qui nous a qui nous a permis de
souffler un peu à la mi-temps le COP de
morpa composé d'une cinquantaine de
supporters est optimiste pour la deuxème
période là ils sont réduit à 10 je pense
qu'on va remporter le match haut la main
et là c'est sûr et certain on va on va
se qualifier pour la finale pour all
tout droit plaisir au retour des
vestiaires Guyon courour accélère et se
procure plusieurs occasions avant de Mar
sur un coup franc dévié par le défenseur
romain ass un partout à la 75e minute
deè mi-temps c'est c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment motivé on a fait une
deè mi-temps extraordinaire on a marqué
un but on a clairement baissé le pied on
avait plus le ballon et et voilà on
prend ce but qui qui nous fait mal mais
voilà il fallait tenir quand même jusque
jusqu'à la fin du match pour pour aller
chercher ces penalties dans la loterie
des tir au but morpose 41 avec un arrêt
du gardien Antoine Baptiste on a eu un
grand gardien ce soir aussi je ti le
féliciter anine qui nous a qui nous a
quand même fait gagner le match sur la
fin on les a très très mal tiré très
très mal tiré très très mal tiré stress
l'envie de gagner l'envie de bien faire
et parfois faut fautut je sais pas j'ai
pas de mot je suis déçu un peu on va on
va essayer de surmonter ça mais ça va
être compliqué en finale de la Coupe des
ivelines Mora affrontera li une équipe
qui a balayé Trapp 2-0 en demi la
rencontre pour le titre se jouera le
dimanche 5 juin à
plaisir
l'équipe féminine du chîn versaill joué
ce weekend en play-off contre ecodin les
joueuses de vinco bardit se sont
inclinés 85 à 59 contre les Nordistes
des codins pour nous parler de cette
rencontre et de ces matchs de play-off
nous recevons sur ce plateau la
Capitelle Julie femme et perine chanlon
qui joue au poste 4 hère non intérieur
intérieur bonsoir alors qu'est-ce qui
n'a pas fonctionner sur cette
rencontre beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses
bah c'est vrai que on c'est des matchs
100 comme ça on sait pas ce qui se passe
pendant tout le match on se demande où
on est en fait on n'est pas là on sait
pas
pourquoi offensivement on était plutôt
dans notre dans notre zone de points
parce qu'on met 59 points et nous on est
plutôt une équipe qui joue longtemps
donc c'est ça encore c'est pas trop le
problème mais ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné en défense on a été vraiment
très mauvaise chacune notre tour c'est
pas une joueuse c'est tout le monde donc
bah voilà le résultat perine et codin
étent largement supérieur au chaîné non
enfin sur ce match puisqu'on na pas été
dedans et que ça nous a pas réussi
effectivement et elles ont été
supérieures ça se voit notamment sur le
score après je pense que c'est pas une
équipe qui
est très très au-dessus de nous je pense
que enfin on joue 10 fois le match 10
fois il y a pas 26 points d'écart donc
on a le match retour on verra le
résultat du match retour mais je pense
pas que ça soit une équipe qui soit
vraiment au-dessus de nous offensivement
vous n'avez marqué que 59 points sur
cette rencontre il y a eu un manque
d'efficacité en attaque
non si vous regardez nos résultats sur
l'année nous on a on a un concept de jeu
qui joue on joue souvent en 20 secondes
donc mathématiquement on n'est pas une
équipe qui va scorer de toute façon 90
points c'est très rare c'est pas notre
fond de commerce donc ça encore c'est
c'est pas du tout 59 points c'est
correct sauf que quand vous regardez on
était la meilleure défense du
championnat et pour le coup en général
on encaisse moins de 50 points une
cinquantaine de points voilà c'est là le
problème c'est pas les points qu'on a
marqué c'est les points qu'on a encaissé
mais offensivement oui il y a eu des des
ratés des petits paniers faciles euh
qu'on qu'on aurait du mettre mais bon
c'est pas non plus une catastrophe
offensivement il faudra apprendre à
scorer peut-être plus vite dans les
prochains matchs si vous êteser d'autant
de points faut surtout mieux défendre
parce que on changera pas notre fusil
d'épaule parce que ce match là ça reste
du sport voilà et hier on est dans un
non match mais quand toute la saison on
perd un seul match c'est pas parce que
hier on perd que on va se dire ça y est
tout ce qu'on a travaillé tout ce qu'on
a mis en en place depuis le début de la
saison c'est c'est plus valable non par
contre il va falloir vraiment faire des
efforts pour être beaucoup plus agressif
défensivement et gérer ce problème là
offensivement on va pas se mettre à
jouer en 10 secondes ça c'est pas
notre non puis on a un
coach qui est pas du tout dans cette
conception donc vous dans la
construction plus que dans l'attaque
direct
euh on est plutôt dans la discipline
dans la discipline et un manque de de
préparation peut-être sur cette
rencontre ou vous avez préparé le match
comme vous vouliez euh pas du tout de
manque de préparation on a pris le temps
de le préparé comme on le voulait on a
travaillé sur vidéo on a vraiment
décortiqué les systèmes adverses donc
non non on a on avait préparé le le
match on connaissait très bien
écodin le résultat c'est vraiment sur un
non match de notre part et et pas sur le
la le manque de préparation qu'on a eu
avant Julie le fait que vous ayez autant
dominé les les phases de poou finalement
quand vous arrivez en play-off il n'y a
pas ce ce petit côté un petit peu
déconcentration il y a pas de
déconcentration se dire finalement qu'il
faut élever son niveau de jeu dans dans
un match clé bah c'est c'est toujours
possible mais aujourd'hui si on nous
pose à chacune la question on va se dire
mais non mais nous on était super motivé
dans lesvestir avant le match on est à
fond
et de pas du tout de démotivation après
effectivement ecodin c'est une équipe
qui jusqu'au dernier moment ne savait
pas si elle allait faire partie des
playoff ou pas donc elle a une saison
qui a été compliqué pour plus que que
nous nous ça fait un moment qu'on sait
qu'on est en play-off qu'on est déjà
focalisé là-dessus et puis bah là
effectivement peut-être quelques
quelques matchs un peu plus difficiles
nous aurait alarméêtre le temps pour
vous remettre en jambe vous remettre
dans les dans les match de toute façon
là on a plus le temps là on y va
maintenant on en a trois et faut les G
gag donc on va tout donner ça c'est
certain donc vous êtes à un point des
premières places c'est encore jouable il
faut pour être là on est maître de notre
destin si on gagne les trois matchs on
est sûr d'être dans les deux qui monent
donc maintenant il en reste trois faut
faire TR sur TR
et il faut même pas penser à en faire
deux faut en faire trois il faut partir
à la guerre pour ces trois derniers
matchs oui comme comme on disait hier on
a perdu une bataille mais on est
toujours dans la dans la guerre
euh on a cet état d'esprit donc je me
fais pas de souci on a on sait qu'on a
trois matchs que le le destin est entre
nos mains et que on va travailler pour
les prendre pas se dire voilà il y a
trois matchs d'abord prendre le premier
gagner le premier et puis après passer
au suivant travailler là on a 15 jours
pour travailler pour le prochain match
et travailler pour gagner ce prochain
match contre Soisson puis les les deux
suivants et mathématiquement si on gagne
les trois on est dans les deux
quiumentes les autres équipes de cette
poule sont
prenables toutes les équipes sont
prenables tout dangereuse voilà on
arrive à un stade de la compétition on
est on est en play-off donc toutes les
équipes sont dangereuses toutes les
équipes se battent pour la montée il y a
aucune équipe qui est là par hasard donc
chaque match sera difficile à jouer ce
match contre Soisson le 8 mai prochain à
domicile ce sera peut-être le tournant
de ce de ce mini championnat euh bah
c'est sûr que si on perd ça devient
compliqué donc on veut même pas
l'envisager euh maintenant c'est
vraiment pour nous ce qui est très
important là c'est de se
dire le championnat il est terminé c'est
un nouveau championnat c'est c'est
complètement autre chose et il faut
oublier tout ce qu'on a fait dominer la
la saison régulière ça c'est c'est du
passé
et je on pensait tous que on s'était mis
ça dans la tête visiblement hier on a eu
un petit revers donc bah maintenant le 8
mai c'est sûr que faut être à 200 % si
on perd mais que les les joueuses on a
donné le maximum et que on aura perdu
mais hier ce qui est plus décevant de
notre part c'est que on a eu cette
sensation de
pas être présente ne pas voilà on était
pas là donc ça c'est embêtant et ça on a
plus le droit de le faire si on perd
c'est avec la manière hier on perd sans
la manière
merci à tous les deux toutes les deux
d'être passé sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite de réaliser un gros match
contre Soisson le 8 mai prochain on
continue de parler du basket dans cette
émission c'était une première dans les
ivelines les championnats de France de
basket militaire étaient organisé au
gymnase malmedon de morpa les match ont
opposé les équipes de l'armée de terre
de l'airire de la marine et de la
gendarmerie au total une centaine de
militaires est venu pour l'événement un
montage de Sandrine
fonteille pendant 3 jours les militaires
ont troqué leur uniforme contre un
maillot de basket à l'occasion des
championnats de France militaire la
deuxème édition était organisée cette
année au gymnase malmedon de morpa les
match ont opposé les équipes de l'armée
de terre de l'IRE la marine et la
gendarmerie c'est les meilleurs joueurs
des sélections de la gendarmerie de la
Marine nationale de l'armée de l'air et
de l'armée de terre qui sont
sélectionnés on fait des stages pour les
détecter et après on les sélectionne
pour venir participer au championnat
France militaire panier à TR points
rebond dunk une centaine de joueurs
venus de toute la France ont fait le
chaud pendant ces 3 jours de compétition
c'est un tournoi qui me tient beaucoup à
cœur parce que ça me permet bah non
seulement voilà de profiter de jouer au
basket dans le cadre du travail c'est
c'est génial et en plus de pouvoir
échanger avec toutes les autres équipes
où je connais évidemment la plupart des
basketteur et à chaque fois c'est un
vrai un vrai plaisir de retrouver tous
mes camarades on m'a contacté et j'ai
saisi l'occasion je pense que j'en
aurais pas 50 occasions comme ça de
partager ces moments l'année dernière
moi j'étais pas je suis nouvelle cette
année et oui oui c'est très très sympa
l'ambiance est vraiment sympa et la
mentalité très sympa aussi l'équipe de
la Marine a remporté la finale contre
l'armée de l'air sur le score de 62 à 55
les meilleurs joueurs du tournoi seront
sélectionnés par le staff de l'équipe de
France militaire pour participer au
championnat du monde de la catégorie la
compétition sera organisée au mois de
juillet à San Diego aux
États-Unis après cette large page basket
on passe au de l'actualité sportive
ivinoise on commence cette rubrique par
du golf l'Open de France qui fête sa
100e édition cette année va accueillir
une star sur les Green de 50 ans en
yelin l'Irlandais rorit à Milroy le
golfer est actuellement à la 3e place du
classement mondial à 26 ans il compte 19
victoires professionnelles le
Britannique participera à son deème Open
de France en 2010 le sportif avait
failli remporter la mise mais c'est
finalement Miguel Andr Jimenez qui avait
rafflé la victoire l'OP de France sera
organisé du 30 juin au 3 juillet on
reste au Golf National de Saint-Quentin
en iveline le parcours de l'albatrous
l'un des plus techniques de France et
qui accueillera les joueurs pendant
l'Open de France de golf rouvre ses
portes au golfeurs ce weekend après 9
mois de travaux les trous numéro 16 et
11 ont été remodelés pour accueillir les
grandes compétitions nationales et
internationales comme la rider Cup 2018
on écoute le superintendant du parcours
Alejandro reyas pourton trouve que que
pour les jur amateur ça va être plus
simple vraiment on va s'amouser ça va
plus amousant on a fait des son des
approches que que ça va être moins
compliqué pour les joueurs amateurs mais
par contre pour les joueurs
professionnels il y a il y a pas mal des
obstacles vont qui vont faire
la à M d'escalade à présent vertical art
situé dans la zone d'activité du pas du
lac à mon organisé une compétition ce
samedi dans la structure pour présenter
ses nouveaux murs une centaine de
personnes a participé à cet événement
baptisé vertical attaque on écoute les
réactions notre journaliste Camille
amambert était sur place le niveau ça va
du débutant sont des personnes qu'on on
même jamais fait qui sont inscrits comme
ça pour s'amuser entre amis jusqu'à des
membres de l'équipe de France donc là on
a vraiment un gros panel comme quoi
c'est un sport et une salle qui est
ouvert vraiment à tout public ça propose
aux gens enfin un contexte où on utilise
on essaie d'optimiser toutes les faces
et de leur proposer les les passages les
plus beau possible quoi pour que bah il
se fasse plaisir encore une fois c'est
le plus
important le 18 juin vertical art
organisera un événement qui devrait
rassembler plus de 300 compétiteurs
handbal le chaîné s'enfonce encore un
peu plus dans la crise les evvinois se
sont inclinés d'un petit but contre
charte 34 à 33 à domicile avec cette
défaite le chaîné est toujours bon
dernier du classement avec un bilan de
deux victoires de nul et 15 défaites
depuis le début de la saison la descente
en National 3 devient de plus en plus
concrète
on termine ce magazine par un
rendez-vous en baseball les coupgardes
de montinil le bretonux reçoivent
Saint-Just ce dimanche à partir de 11h
au stade jean-maréchal de Montini le
Bretonneux les îes montains restent sur
un bilan de trois victoires et une
défaite depuis le début de la saison un
parcours qui est place aux première
place de cette 2uxe division la montée
l'objectif fixé en début de saison
estant bonne voie c'est la fin de ce 78
sport merci d' l'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine n'oubliez pas de regarder les
reportag sur Youtube mais également sur
notre site internet très belle soirée
sur TVfil